oh i got him i'm back on now yeah i hear
it i hear it oh
okay okay hold on i'm about to be able
to hear myself i think the ladies every
time i tell you to call nicole they seem
to interrupt you don't want us to call
nicole
i think you should call francesca
um uh-oh explain fill me in are you
friends with her
fill me in yeah what's what's the status
now no caroline tell us and the audience
he was just in mexico with her last week
so i'm just curious to know
is she from the show too yes yes and did
you have sex with her
no she had a boyfriend another boyfriend
from this but but the fact when you say
did you have a why don't you call harry
and he doesn't answer who's harry
francesca's boyfriend from oh i thought
that was the they're not taking a little
cute name they had for her private
he knows for a fact they're not together
he said that very clearly so why do you
they're not together um because of your
trip to mexico
no that came much later um who came
later
no it's just yeah so you're sweating
uh yes well me and francesco are very
good friends i'm
good friends with lots of people from
the castle phone her we'll put it that
way
she is very busy she's very busy she's
doing musicians she's in the group
everybody's playing in a band she's in
mexico right now let's say she doesn't
have service i would stay i stayed there
for a week the service is pretty tough
down there
so dial it dial it
go ahead here we go um dalit
um you know what i can't i can't well
she's she's nice looking yeah she is she
doesn't look busy
i she does not look busy okay you guys
suck so bad for that by the way okay
phone we can't i can't i cannot it'll be
me i'll say i did it i'll talk to her i
oh um no francesco and harry have sex
in season one yeah and then you
scooched into that oh gosh connection
i'm getting now
no no no it's no no no no okay so then
call harry i can't
i don't have various numbers the only
thing you should call harry that that's
not gonna happen i'll tell you that
let's call harry that that's one thing
that can't
anyways let's change the subject yeah
producers in the back can we
can we chase it listen i had a great
time on the show i've had a great time
since i'm having a great time right now
with you guys
um anyway so howie what are you up to
these days how's how's life
nicole or no no no no no no no
call francesca hey let's call francesca
yeah i'll talk to her i'll text her
what is texting on i'll say i'm on a i'm
on a podcast right now and said okay if
i call you
just okay let's see what she says okay
and also my d if you don't feel
comfortable calling you can pass along
her phone number my dad can call yeah
give me francesca's phone number that's
all my wife needs to find is francesca's
number
in my phone who's francesca howie
you don't know francesca she's too hot
she's probably she's probably really
busy shooting her uh
all of her content but we'll see but
your content was speaking going back to
that when they found you
they were no they know from your
instagram account that you had a lot of
sex
there's a a well
we have another instagram account my
brother and i barrett called boat
chronicles
and as bono a fellow boat owner yourself
you know sometimes at a time or bone
boner
bone chronicles what would you say boat
chronicles oh i'm sorry
it might as well be the same thing no
but we have float in your mouth
wherever you put the bone so anyways
maybe i gotta found
a name for our vote did she text back
she has not yet
she has not yet i will let you know if
she how do you meet such busy women
they're they are very they're successful
successful busy women but
i don't know i might have to come back
on if she does we'll find out anyways
i'm very nervous i really hope she
doesn't text back
just what it is we're all very we're all
very good friends um very good friends
we're all very good friends with
benefits
very good friends we are very good
friends how proud is jim
you have to my dad's a big fan of
francesca he's met francesca before
he's a big fan he's a big you like he's
been nicole as well of course
but he's a he's a big fan are you a fan
of these girls jim
absolutely they're they've all been on
the boat and they're
wonderful when you call the oh the boat
is where you guys live
yeah where i live yeah my dad lives
nearby yeah so they when you say they've
all been
on the boat are you referring to an
actual boat or is that the nickname
for bryce's private part yeah yeah
there they are there you go there they
are some shots oh yeah so there's
there's nicole and i
um where's nicole in you down down low
kind of like down low there you are
there they are is that on the boat
and what are you doing there on the boat
which one well we were holding on to the
cables
oh no that was that was actually my
friend's boat i wanted to switch it up
and do a little sailboat actually
tomorrow's a powerboat
but there's an aerial shot of ours and
boatingmagazine.com right there
that's what it looks like so based on
these aerial shots the producers of too
hot to handle go this guy gets a lot of
a lot well if you want to see what
really made we've really sold google
boat chronicles
boat chronicles boat chronicles on
instagram this is what when you want to
look for somebody
my son is here too yeah alex alex you
saw both chronicles right
have you seen both chronicles yes yes
yes he's not on mike
is this going well uh is your life
anything like bryce's alex
my son i'm hoping what what do you think
now it is that's true oh my gosh i do my
best
um oh you did you did better than yes so
we have all of our
oh my gosh who are these people right so
we have um
let's call her yes yeah we see that's
charlie jordan that's
uh that's a few other girls that are on
the boat there's somebody else
who is doing uh uh synchronized swimming
yeah that was actually a shot in mexico
that's a friend of mine her name's megan
um there's um there's a lot of who's
that
who's that that's a little video i want
to click a video and see what it looks
like can you play it
play that video did you have sex with
charlie uh
again i would like to keep the person no
i didn't sexually are just
friends just friends all right well he
answered that very quickly
so i'm thinking the ones he didn't
answer very quickly were obvious
yeses we're all just friends what
percentage of the cast have you
uh been with intimately very i don't
know 10
then right
aren't there ten people on a cast yeah
so you you told us two already okay so
twenty percent right it's going up
because it's because it's my
myself too you know oh so then that's
thirty self crack
and then that's thirty percent yeah it's
myself too yeah
it's myself too you know so so yeah
that's that's both chronicles so they
watch something like this and they say
this guy's probably
having a lot of fun and uh and yeah you
are
having who's the captain of the boat
well when it's not me it's big jim in
the back my dad he likes
you you think i have a good time at the
boat right my dad just hangs back with
the camera phone
all drivers i'll drive you and whenever
you like friends exactly
you want to set up a play date today
yeah yeah he's like can we take the butt
out this weekend yeah dad sure
sure alex i'll drive the boat yeah it's
like parties
we have fun there's a there's a picture
if you scroll down a couple more i think
the one that they've really liked
a little more a little more is um look a
sausage party oh yeah
right exactly they ignored all those
actually i don't know i'm going to pass
it
if you go i don't know i might have
passed it we take a lot of pictures
maybe it's a little more i love that
you've got all these pictures memorized
yeah it's been a while since i've seen
the bow chronicles page actually my
brother runs it
to be fair your brother takes the
pictures your father drives the boat and
you just make all the friends exactly
like the one in the bottom left corner i
like that picture right there
so they'll see a picture like that and
they'll say this guy
this guy is probably a lot of fun really
to me it looks like this guy's trying to
butt in line
no i do something they'll cut me off i'm
like excuse me i'm just trying to take a
picture here
it looks like look at the caption lost
count
i thought it was clever because of the
emojis the ones and you know what it
looks like to me
it looks like there's a big sale at
forever 21 and he's trying to get in
line to buy something for his girlfriend
i'm sorry
i'm what are you guys all looking at
that's why i messed hey what are you
guys all looking at
but that was just me trying to be like
excuse me my name is bryce and you could
name
all the women in this absolutely not oh
absolutely not i know it's a couple of
them
wow but anyways um so if someone wants
to get on the show
text back look he's sweating did she
text back she does not text back thank
god let's try to she's usually really
bad
with her phones she's really bad with
her phone yeah you know young women on
instagram are always really bad with
their phones
they're never around when they're being
called or texted
you never see a young woman on her phone
she does that she has had the millions
and millions and millions of followers
she's very very popular does she have
millions of followers
francesca francesca does yes okay let's
call her
let's just call her i won't do anything
you can hang up your phone you're
controlling your phone if i say
something wrong
and then you can blame it on me um
he's no longer friends with alex alex
is that phlegm yeah a little bit could
be all right we gotta get out of here
quickly
um yeah i've no i've lost my francesca
farago
we don't have father to go so conor the
big the big reason
uh i'm gonna just call her as a fan just
let me call her
so the big reason why people the rumors
have started of uh francesca nice
because we because she left harry for
you no no should we just we posted lots
of tick tocks together
and stuff like that and once why do
people see a tick tock
and then jump to conclusions we made
them pretty darn uh
scandalous so there was no conclusion
you said you had sex with her
no i don't know we just you did i said
you went to mexico and you had sex with
me i never said that
yes you did oh you can't tell me i said
that one oh
we gotta win the playback back what do
you think co-host i don't think i said
that
um definitely didn't say that i'm going
to take my dad's side but
but i think he's right i don't think i
said it i don't think i said it i
think you uh caroline mckenzie
did you get a sense that he had sex with
francesca
what do you think i'm asking what you
think without asking him
i feel like this is his own private
thank you thank you so much
okay thank you so much you're right
you're right thank you so much there's
nothing more important than privacy on
anybody's podcast
when you're a guest on a podcast
privacy is but he said it